[Music]
in buzzkill news hmm submitted by hey
you single ooh nope nope nope saying go
to bed at the rainbow nobody here is
single maybe ecologist writing to send
drunk pictures to students parents will
the [ __ ] is taking the pictures on
behalf of the college yeah okay right
probably posted from Instagram to
Facebook
okay wait you're telling me the
university has enough money to pay for a
person to sit there all day getting
these pictures yep for every student
right universities have a lot of money
they need to use their money more ways
probably a senior taking pictures of
freshmen you know those campus security
they're usually just seniors or juniors
like they're hiring narcs you mean are
like yeah they're usually they're
usually students just older students
like the dorm people yeah cuz not
thanked the campus police actually
police officers are are a resident hope
if I have a daughter she doesn't go to
college and become a [ __ ] [ __ ] dumpster
Oh oh god you know they got to do it
earlier in life I think they should like
Viacom comes to first college they're
not like 40 in like with kids and then
they're like I've only had one but never
had big like I wanted it yep
I just don't want them to go to college
on us and they're like you know I could
just have come all over me it's like
I've never restricted you before I don't
think any woman goes into college saying
like it's time for the comma
they're trying to avoid the comb like
it's the plague yeah that was a good
thing you're dodging it like it's coming
at your face exactly can I can I know I
feel like that only happens will mainly
happens to the women or girls that like
are super [ __ ] repressed hmm and then
when they go into skew they have alcohol
they get a little dick and they just
cannot resist anymore well you know
those Instagram handles they're just all
kids getting drunk you've seen that no I
know what you're on it I'm on it
no no I mean like I will have a daughter
yes making sure she's not on it no she's
actually way more grandma than me she's
making sure I'm not on it Oh mom are you
[ __ ] serious that's very
be more wild than your kid and bill
turbit but I bet you they're tagging
them and then somehow I don't know
schools need to do something better with
their budgets are finding them and then
I have a question yes since you have a
20 she's 20 right did you have instances
where your daughter did want to hang out
with you because you're also very young
and you're also very attractive so it's
like get away mom like my [ __ ]
friends are looking at you know we are
friends and we party together so she had
a face so she'll come with me cuz you
know mom needs a mimosa and then she'll
drive me home and she's the best
we're like Gd yeah that's all tightly
that's amazing yeah you guys should you
get I can't wait for your son to be 20 I
hope we're friends I'ma be like 60 by
the time he's 20 you'll still be
partying and he'll still driving are
true yes
University is in China all right yeah
none Arts University the Yunnan beat you
none human be yeah so that University
has announced that they will be if they
catch their students being drunk they're
gonna take a photo and not just tech
Chinese students drink yeah their main
gate of the university faces as a street
that's full of bars oh I just can't
picture Asian kids having the same type
of college life that we do you know I
just picture like like the engineering
department at a American school I just
imagine the entire school in China is
like that where everyone's a [ __ ]
geek nerd just trying to [ __ ] I
picture asian-american kids getting down
but I can't picture Asians and Asian
well I can't if they're like [ __ ]
Korean yeah oh yeah but Chinese kids I'm
not sure guys I know that Creek kids
drink all the [ __ ] time
but is it specifically they don't want
kids under 21 drinking they don't really
mention age is just the fact that it's
like taking away from their study well
yeah like their caffeine is aimed to
promoting safety on campus and so
somehow that correlates to them not
wanting them to get drunk safety first
yeah yeah you know what this is gonna
promote them drinking behind everybody's
and that's even worse no no that's why I
do my University's saying that they want
they won't just text the photo or like
send it through REIT at WeChat but they
will actually print the Bell we're gonna
develop the photograph okay so the
parents can put it up on the fridge room
do the wall mount some one-hour photo
development and then we're gonna say
they have a team that goes and there's
fools in the [ __ ] room that is a
waste of time like it's a waste of time
and also I feel like the school
shouldn't be involved in their personal
lives to like a wave their budding
hanbei it's University it's not [ __ ]
elementary school I don't know different
countries that's just Asian style though
yeah I'm saying it from an American
perspective but you know I know like in
even like in Korea like an you'll see
like a officer like spank your kid and
you're like good job yeah you know so
it's like it's different stuff you get
more Tarkin King Joffrey yeah like yeah
and that's really what happens so it'd
be too far for you then like if I'm in
Korea I don't know it depends it's the
culture it's the coat yeah we can't
really impose what we think is right or
wrong
yeah be culturally sensitive we're here
as Americans listening to it so we're
not gonna be like well that's them
moving on that is exactly what I'm gonna
do we have no conversation is my point
well I think the thing is you got to
understand why they do it this way too
so the way that the way it is it's like
when you give your kid off to school now
it's their job to also be parent to
that's what you're expecting them to do
not only just teach them academics but
also raise them up to be like good human
beings like that like a parent so then
when you send them there it's like oh
[ __ ] thank you for also parent and I'm
also gauging the threshold so for
example because I know that about Asian
culture if they're doing that they're
taking pictures that to me is still part
of the threshold but if they started
caning kids for drinking or chaining
them to their bed posts at night so they
don't go out to the bars I'm like for
their threshold that's really bad but
depending on which country I'm looking
at I have to put those glasses on right
and culturally sensitive right best
Singapore
I already feel like that's reaching
their threshold because there's a news
article on it because I'm assuming that
it's kind of a little bit out there even
that's probably written by Rachel Harris
or something no you are mentioning in
this article that the students are
protesting what the [ __ ] I'm part of
this I have Instagram I know what they
do in America so I just saw hashtag it's
kind of not so sad it sounds like it's
kind of reaching their threshold in
their own country you know if it's not
then why are we talking about it yeah I
mean yeah I just want to see what a
[ __ ] Chinese college party looks like
I bet it's wild for real yeah because
they're sober Pratt yeah you know what I
mean like they're under so much control
that now they have this freedom that I
feel like it's [ __ ] wild a newly
public oh I feel like it's both my
friend my friends just a straight-up
like geek out here but he went to
Beijing University to teach English and
he was getting Maris's really yeah
regular Chinese guy but good and he was
like just [ __ ] he was swimming and
[ __ ] you on [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean
like it's like non-stop like I went to
be went to go visit him and it he was
like yeah dude like everyone here
they're so [ __ ] repressed that like
one after the other huh and he's like
and if you speak English you're super
hot to them everybody's such dicks here
Bo that's why you don't want to leave
look at your cousin your cousin's
[ __ ] wild but he comes out here
you're just like a bob you know name me
but he has like all these crazy ass
story yeah but he was part of the under
was a criminal so what I'm like he looks
like a geek like they still have that
culture out there to you that's Jim
you're stereotyping your own people bar
who do you that would have been a family
we brought me to meet his thug friends I
thought they're all losers
I like dude I would just [ __ ] beat
the [ __ ] out of all of you hear their
stories and I'm like I'm you guys
[ __ ] chop people up with like bamboo
knives that's pretty scary
yeah they don't have guns out there so
they use the knives that they used to
chop down butchered like a machete
they've got Taiwanese me show you that
chops down bamboo cuz hella bamboo there
they use that to chop people up in the
streets what is right all those they
look like ye yeah
you see two guys on a scooter shooting
people I think personal it's riding the
other dudes holding them like the
[ __ ] boots on each other
[Laughter]
nice fly big guy
are you talking about earlier in a
different article I guess yeah but look
at it on his shoulder machete and drive
my cutter scooter cuts does your
daughter like every party though I have
you ever had like an infant oh yeah
comes home like [ __ ] wasted no cuz
she has a really good gauge she's a good
kid but she'll have girlfriends over for
like Valentine's Day that Valentine's
Day and I bought them you know I bought
them alcohol hell yeah
20 so it's fine but the only condition
was that they stay home and they don't
drive anywhere that's dope
yeah and then they had finally ordered
pizza they eat chocolate they watched
Jornal pizza yeah yeah it was dude
actually was it was we get the kind okay
yeah I think it would seem Stone and
they did arms only but yeah they were
great I mean friends do the spider-man
and weird
your arms only do the spider-man yeah I
just you're just you're such a cool
parent I want to be the embarrassing
parent when my kid never wants to be
around me
oh hi I want my kids to go through what
I did yeah like everyone thought my
parents were my grandparents like I want
them to love me like in our own quarters
but like around their friends I want to
embarrass the [ __ ] out of them see when
her friends are around
I think I'm their friend too and it's
very embarrassing for her cuz she's like
mom like you're not the cool mom no I am
the cool mom in my head I think I'm a
cool mom I'm like I'm a cool mom and
she's like mom can you just drop off or
alcohol and like go back out to the
living room and I'm like you're all like
on your phone in your room like bored
and [ __ ] like but whatever conversation
like your friends like me too yeah I
just want to be that parent that uses
slang that I should never use yeah yeah
and he's walking hey guys we're gonna
get lit up tonight
no and you know all right Cole whatever
I think that'd be hilarious yeah liddie
and I clearly my mom for a mean girl
though exactly I want to be her I want
to be her so [ __ ] bad you have no
idea ya know what's up but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna do it though I'm embarrass
the [ __ ] out
[Music]